family I'm going to start the year fresh
can't you see I want to start the year
clean and
[Music]
fresh right boys and girls we're back
and like we always say from the jump we
just get straight into it we pull them
to the side and we just go damn bro you
pull them to the side and we just go man
just oh spitting
spit all right let's go let's go spit
and split spit and split as we do and of
obviously of course we have the question
of the week and the question of the week
was mom/dad math mom/dad math all right
you already know the trend has been
going and been going and been going
between the boy math girl math this math
that math and your boys are are sheep
like the rest of them we're no better
than the rest of them we are no better
but we are the best facts yeah yeah yeah
doesn't make sense we just when you say
it with chess it doesn't matter doesn't
need to make sense doesn't make sense
but it makes sense come
on come on
cool cool right Mom Dad math mom math is
calling me into her room to get the
remote 6 in away from her hand I've
never been treated like that but yeah I
I have
that's I have it's the it's and it's
it's facts it's always the
yeah my pops my pops will get up or if
what my pops will do if he knows he
can't be bothered to get up and change
his channel he's just falling asleep
where he is the TV's on and he's falling
asleep where he is bro my mom will call
me yeah and she won't tell you what's
going on either just say fuad and let
the air sit and let the air just just
let it sit I'm be like Mom yeah Mom
nothing bro until she starts hearing me
walking and saying mom then she'll be
like oh come and get this thing for me
cuz she knows I'll screw
ah she knows I'll screw it's jarring my
days dad math is driving 5 miles out of
town cuz the petrol is three p cheaper
damn that's backwards math yeah that's
that's that's hell backwards backwards
math my math is getting you to sleep
early 2 weeks before school starts to
get into a routine oh that's going to be
Vex I knew it that's going to be Vex bro
I knew it that's so fact yeah it is and
that's obviously M oh you need the
routine school starts in two week
bro out my face it's 8:00 p.m. and the
sun's out yeah it's out and I can still
hear the the hoses spraying I can hear
the P of everything else giggling is is
still spraying yeah man it's still
spraying allow it man God God uh giving
you trauma as a kid but then denying it
all when you're an adult
mhm
preach dad math is them saying are you
going to challenge me when you prove
them wrong oh my God
I can hear it in a Nigerian English
accent so well swear are you going to
challenge me oh yeah no no no no I've
never I've never had that confrontation
in my life are you going to challenge me
you're just a you you know just speaking
facts you ask me a question I answer and
the response is are you going to
challenge me this isn't the animal
kingdom don't I'm not challenging anyone
I'm just speaking dad allow me challenge
me wow there there's so much Authority
in that Authority in that word challenge
yeah facts are you ready to take over
cuz here I am facts are you ready to
take over are you ready to start paying
bills that's clearly what he's asking
bro no no no no
scary M math is grabbing her sorry mmth
is grabbing her hand when she tries to
hit you equals you are trying to kill
her yeah
[Music]
fact when you try and Dodge and she
starts oh no yeah bro you dodge that
punch she to the floor say he hit me he
hit me Mom stop all lies stop all these
lies before Dad gets
home bur me you MK me stop it that's
crazy M math is coming home from work
and getting angry at your children
relaxing James James I don't think you
might understand how Blissful my life
was between like 3 and 6 every day when
I got back home from school
Dragon Ball Z bit of trouble TV bit of
Nickelodeon 6:00 I'd hear my pops on my
mom's car door slam and the PTSD will
stop flowing livid bro I remember the
anxiety and the even if I've done
nothing or I've know I've done
everything I need to do before they get
in I'm still like [__] play time's over
bro play time's over I remember coming
home and
thinking cuz I used to mitigate that by
always being out okay and I used to come
in at my curfew and when I open that
door m
bro I used to have to play My Steps
perfect I open that door I have to say
hello to everyone bro if I made it from
the door to the kitchen without
announcing myself and saying hello
beef beef
bro that's yeah it's stupid man just
come on let us live as kids as children
your child being Vex your kids for
relaxing is crazy I remember it like it
was yesterday Saturday morning facts bro
Saturday morning morning if the washing
up wasn't done from the night before
brother arms ah there's one on here
facts actually there's literally one on
here I'll go to that one right now M
math is it being 9:00 a.m. on a Saturday
and her screaming are you going to sleep
all
day are you going to sleep all day big
man is a weekend and it's 9:00 yeah let
me sleep just let me sleep you're going
to sleep one day is right bro bro it's
the most Charing thing I know it's chore
day but relax the chores aren't going
anywhere oh bro the sound of that Hoover
on a Saturday waking me up the most
jarring thing possible I remember my mom
used to do this I've said this to on the
Pod before my mom used to do this all
the time this when I was still working
at girl on the market and obviously my I
I knew I was livid every day because I
worked the longest shifts out of
everyone in my family yeah and I'm like
just let me rest bro I've got a 12-hour
shift tomorrow let me rest every morning
before my mom would leave to work she
would wake me up bear in mind I probably
had about 5 hours 6 hours sleep at this
point she would wake me up tell me the
chores to do not to forget and then
leave I was like you know I have a phone
[__] text me literally text me put
put the fridge all the time stop waking
me up please text me and she gets mad at
me for me having an attitude at her yeah
yeah yeah of course you're putting me in
this
position you're putting me in this
position I'm trying to be fresh for work
you're [__] talking about do the
dishes text
me it's so frustrating 100 oh I remember
like it was yesterday bro every week
without fail oh my moms know they they
know what they're doing I don't know why
they do it of course they do bro it's
their little entertainment so much it's
their little entertainment before they
they Scurry off to make some money it's
the only pleasantry they've got daring
it's actually getting me Ved it's not a
funny thread it's just a PTSD thread it
is a PTSD it's a trauma thread oh God uh
M math is um M math is them asking you
if you know your school workor like you
know those
songs I remember that I've never had
that one oh yeah yeah yeah you know your
school songs yeah this primary school
early secondary school days all you knew
as music oh yeah why are you not allowed
to just be enjoy Stu family parents
don't want their kids to have fun they
don't period they don't they don't they
don't I can the thing is like
as an adult now we're we're all 32 prop
from Mist right we're deep in how hard
not necessarily how hard life is but how
stressful days can actually be yeah and
I can imagine us now going back to yard
and just seeing kids just spread out my
days beening everyone I'm sping all
three of you in a row line up so I can
clatter you as an Etc like T I don't
want to wave my hand more than once
ET because you I can't come home from a
long day and see you man running around
having fun I've just done a three-hour
commute [__] yeah I've done a three
commute why you laughing F why you
laughing sit down a
Shar I'm hungry [__] you laughing at no
one made me food no I'm the bread winner
and there's no food on the table [__]
bread I get it I get it you see what I'm
saying but as a child L yeah I didn't
ask for this life facts facts I didn't
ask to be born bro I used to I remember
the the one smackable offense all the
time when I lost my temper as a kid yeah
whenever my mom was like you have no
respect I gave birth to you and I've
raised you I used say That's the Law
yeah facts it's the
law rubbing that my face would never say
that but facts I said that twice wow I
would be here yeah yeah I was
dodging I said it twice my life was
dodging bro Oh my days I would to be
here wow I remember saying bro you
moving like an ass to be born yeah [__]
it's the Lord to take care of me don't
use that as as the the bare minimum oh
god oh bro he I used to get crazy but
yeah the fun aspect is mad it is it is
you see what I'm saying though it's mad
I remember one
time one time I asked my mom if on one
summer's day one summer's day I asked my
mom can we go have a water fight me and
my brother she said yeah yeah do your
thing she cussed us for coming in
wet she lost her [__] she was like look
at [__] I like it's a war fight it's a
[__] War fight bro and she was like
you're taking a piss look at your
[__] clothes you're soaking up the
thing I I don't understand I can't win
and she can't win she wanted us to
do yeah yeah every Dodge everything play
play water just water the flowers
oh god oh bro jarring very much so all
right Mom Dad math
Dad Dad math this has happened to me so
many times dad math is making you fetch
the belt for your own
beating that's crazy
[__] my pops will just say go go go and
pick a belt pick a belt go pick a bro
you start do ma you're not allowed to
pick the skin then he's like yeah it
will lick my skin off it will the skinny
ones will lick my skin
off go and pick a belt oh my bro nah I'm
sorry I'm sorry bro I'm sorry no no no
no no no no no no that's fair go and
pick a belt there I'm I'm leaving I'm
running away bro but you're not cuz when
you're back it's even I've told you man
the story I've tried to run away before
I didn't make it far I made it to school
and back they beat me you man they beat
me
[__]
bro I no no no no the Mad thing about
difference between your parents and my
parents yeah
yeah if I tried to run
away there would be no beatings ensued
okay the level of pure victim that my
mom would play in those moments bro I'll
never hear the end of it oh swear I'll
never hear the end of it she'll run
she'll run to her room like I beat
her she'll run to her room slam the door
and cry so
loudly and ask God why bro stop all of
that I'm leaving of you what did I do
for this level of disrespect oh my God
this level of disdain that's joke what
did I do that's joke bro yeah jar I
would have been guilt tripped for 4
weeks damn yeah I would have been beat
that first day and being bruised for
weeks my days I tried to run away before
it just didn't work
bro I don't even know what prompted me
to do it oh I F picking belts is what
prompted you to do it probably but I
don't know what I don't know what I
thought was I don't know what I thought
I was going to achieve out of it do you
see what I'm saying you're tible you're
not supposed to know it was Bonkers to
me I was in primary school I remember I
was one point I was so this is so
dramatic I was so over this curfew
[__] yeah I so over the bullying
teasing
yeah I started looking at holes in
bushes as you're just walking down like
a cycle path you'll see like a little
just like a little Cru space in a bush
and you
think I could ra just live there I could
live there no one's going to fire me bro
and it looks kind of cozy wow then I can
stay out as long as I want wow bro
obviously I'm talking about you yeah
clearly bro yeah and I used to look at
like homeless people and I us think it
doesn't look that bad got cush yeah it
looks as [__] what do you mean you got
two sleeping bags that's crazy bro oh
two sleeping bags and your Hat's full of
coins I'm not seeing money like
that you seem to be doing just fine yeah
yeah yeah wow yeah but that that pick a
belting is crazy brother yeah fetch
fetch your weapon right my math is make
you clean the entire house for guests
that aren't going to leave the living
room [__] facts bro when telling me
to clean my room because her friend's
coming over is the most nuts thing ever
the most nuts thing if for me my mom
would say why haven't you changed my bed
sheets it's New Year's
Eve
stop stop stop she said you need to
start the year fresh that's not why
haven't you changed my bed sheet that's
not a sentence a human being is said I'm
telling you Niger
get away with
murder murder James
it's why I can't even you lost me in the
first half why haven't you changed my
bed
sheets oh stand up I I mean obviously
I'll get sat backed down but in that
moment I'll stand up and then to finish
it off the confidence it's New Year's
Eve the [__] does that mean to me I want
to family I want to start the year fresh
can't you see you want to start the year
clean and
fresh [__] I can't hear stuff like that
see I want to start
cleaner yes some of the stuff I've been
I've been told is is so barbaric bro
can't you see I want to start the year
clean and
fresh change my bed sheets wow
I couldn't hear that in a Nigerian
accent oh brother it spin me brother
it's so
barbaric it will spin me
bro the drawes they give
us anyway oh god um
yeah yeah go
go Dad math is taking the money that was
given to you by a relative and saying
they're going to hold it for you been
there so many times oh bro so many times
bro bro literally dad math is asking me
the same math question whilst there's
tears in my
eyes oh [__] that's bullying that's just
bullying whilst there's tears in my
eyes that's Jo the next one good good
dad math is having kids with multiple
women and expecting everyone to have one
happy
[Laughter]
family oh Dad's you dads have a sense of
delusion that doesn't they demand
respect in every facet factual so if my
four baby moms are not getting along
yeah where do you man get the audacity
fact I work 12 hours a day fact I
provide for all of you I provide for all
you shut up and get along shut up shut
up you're going to put me in early grade
facts you the man don't want that yeah
he's going to provide and then when I
was 17 kids I'm complaining no one ever
comes to see me no one ever comes to see
me bro after all I've done for you man
oh God all right I got a few more to go
oh God
yeah M math is them having a bad dream
so you can't go out a I've never had
that one but I've I've heard it that's
crazy
mom/dad math is not letting you stay out
late but comfortably sending you to
another country to
study that's me to be fair that's that's
that's me when the way you man say that
so comfortably is always spun me oh
we've got sent to wherever to study yeah
like the fact that like you're strict in
this household but you're willing to
send me across the world yeah facts by
myself facts bro yeah that's
crazy it's factual it's just factual
yeah
Jesus mom math is beating your kids
before church and wondering why they
won't praise the
Lord oh my
God oh
God M math bad grades equals early
pregnancy coming home late from school
early pregnancy sleeping in early
pregnancy
oh
[__] all right two more okay my head's
pounding bro dad math is what is them
lecturing you about what they've
achieved when they were your age after
giving you an ass
whooping 100 all dads have have won a a
god Med of the Olympics by age 11 oh
facts but you know when I was your age
I've done when I was your age I was
walking miles to school when you were my
age I was like
1974 bro so relax literally I don't want
to be your yeah so relax literally God
it's jarring anyway last one dad math
always broke his always broke for his
kids but manages to send money back
home interesting damn interesting damn
but yeah that was M death this was
literally like foreign m and d yeah yeah
yeah facts facts this this is like yeah
first
generation immigrant Mom and Dad yeah
yeah that's ex what it was I was locked
in I was there hear Mom and Dad math M
all right that's that's roses oh is it I
reckon I reckon I remember well mine was
white but Irish white is a different
white yeah it's not Rosy yeah it's more
thorny Irish white is a different white
it's more thorny yeah bro Jes wow right
welcome sorry I cut you off no I was
going to say I said literally said
welcome oh welcome guys thank you for
being with us as always we need you to
head on over to patreon.com gigs
contribute a nice3 a month day and be a
top boy or a top girl if you're not a
top boy what are
you bottom boy sorry I wasn't I wasn't
on bottom boy I'm I'm here now sorry wow
sorry I'm here I'm here I'm here I'm
here I'm here wow I'm here I'm here I'm
here I clocked it like 3 seconds late
but I'm here saw I'm here if you're not
a top boy you're a bottom boy FAS is
moving like a b boy s
anyway patreon.com gigs £3 a month run
the piz get all the exclusive episodes
over there every single Thursday years
and years and years worth of backlog if
you're like a little binge four years to
be exact four years of backlog if you're
like a little bingy wiy M if you're
watching us on YouTube please subscribe
to the channel if you're listening to us
leave a nice review we're not doing top
five today cuz fua couldn't find
something
juicy but I have something else that's
juicy we have something else that's
juicy intro
you right
so I have had the
privilege of watching Godfathers of
Harlem not going to lie to you man
Lion's gate plus they know what they're
doing I'm not going to lie to you man
either Lions of gate plus do know what
they're doing they're doing yeah Lions
Gate plus scroll through the catalog did
I watch some Godfather of Harlem yeah
did I realize it's a alas cast yeah yeah
I did yeah cast is strong was I Gob SM
little bit cast is strong talk to me
Daddy so Godfather's a harem those that
you that don't know it's um stars Forest
Whitaker he is named Ellsworth Bumpy
Johnson and it's basically um based in
Harlem like the 1960s 1963 to be exact
is the um is when it starts it's
basically the blacks versus the Italians
in the heroin business on Road that's
all it is the blacks versus the Italians
and it's just mob beef after mob beef
after mob beef after mob beef so I'm
going to quickly give a Roundup synopsis
of each character before we go on to uh
season 3 every one so Forest whe K like
I said his name is Ellsworth he's actual
first name is Ellsworth but everyone
calls him bumpy um he is married to M
they have a daughter called Margaret
right so um they've whilst U Forest W or
bumpy was in jail R May been happy
family roses BL doing that thing um he's
come back now and his first order of
business is I need to be back on road
bro I want my C I want my cut back and I
need to be I need to be top done of
Harlem all he keeps saying is Harlem is
mine Harlem is mine Harlem is mine and
he wants it to be his like he never left
like he never left my man Vincent on the
other hand Gigante has has other plans
he's so Vince Gigante is one of the
Italian uh bosses one of the five
families and it's basically a war
between bumpy and Vincent
jante but on the side with bumpy and uh
M uh the wife the daughter Margaret is
going through stuff and it's trying to
figure out Wan Wan Wan and we figure out
that Elise who is um antoinet Crown
Legacy or Crow Legacy rather Elise is
actually Bumpy's actual daughter yeah
Mar they adopted Marg in it yes not even
adopted oh I didn't F fam she's an a
dick I saw her shaking in
recovery she's an REM she's an addict
she's they so that's why bumpy swiped a
daughter from her so the actual Margaret
daughter is elise's daughter so that's
Bumpy's the grandfather but Margaret has
no clue Margaret is the actual daughter
she has no clue but M and all of them
like just keeping it a secret keeping it
a bloody secret Stella Gigante now so
Stella is the daughter of Vincent
jigante um father of the five family or
one of the five families she's dating a
black brother and they don't like it one
bit in the
1960s
R they don't like it one bit one bit is
an understatement and she's willing to
risk it all she's willing to risk the
whole thing for my man the whole thing
for my man all my man does is he sing
one song throughout the whole season and
they want him gone they want him gone so
he hires Rafi there Ernie at the bottom
left he he he hdes nzi like my daughter
seeing this spr I don't like it I want
you to take her out find out some
information and then obviously top man
pause they go to a go to like a one of
these Jazz cafes or whatever and he pops
the wrong brother he pops Teddy Teddy is
the boyfriend of Stella so they popped
one of Teddy's boys who's just another
black brother that's singing in the
dance obviously Stella Stella's like
how did this happen because T Teddy's
obviously grieving like ra my boy's dead
I don't even know W Guan then Stella
start putting two and two together oh it
must have been my man hide from my pops
cool so you can already tell this
internal beef it's a civil war in the
yard it's a civil war in the yard so do
you random do you remember I asked you
man a question it could have been on
patreon episode about if you were a uh
villain in a show how would you want to
dppy the antagonist or something like
that do you remember and do you remember
what I said no I said about slicing him
out with a throat with a tin oh my God
yes you did yeah bumpy I've SE I've seen
him do it twice that's bumpy does he
slices man he doesn't think he just
slices he gets a razor blade that they
do feel like like Shape Up thing you're
gone bro one scene I saw I know I know
exactly SC I'm talking about that when
he was trying to patn a deal with Donnie
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah patn a deal
everything's calm he was like this is
what I want to do this is what we should
do gas gas gas gas gas gas gas gas gas
and Don is like bro I appreciate you
you're a legend it's I'm not going to
lie to you I don't think he's going to
pattern yeah and Bob's like you know
what fair play I tried it didn't work
Don was like fair play they shook hands
he didn't think about it bro St my way
highway go his own skin like skin tones
bro another black brother just sliced
him sliced him bro in his in his Club in
his own club on his own club on his
birthday sliced his neck bumpy doesn't
play he doesn't play at all Anyway
season one ends um with somewhat of a
Twist because um obviously like I said
um Stella is dating his black brother um
killed the wrong bre they but they
actually finally kill him Stell
obviously
livid um and Ellsworth tries to like
figure out how to make moves considering
they've got like internal problems with
the Gigante family but season two it
boils down to them trying
to get their French Connection so in
season 2 it's all about the French
connect um getting all the heroin from
Mars and this guy is D bro they he yeah
DOI
get that
from and when I say they Supply they
Supply um the Italians they're like cool
this is our supply this is our guy gang
gang gang gang gang obviously bump's not
having it he wants pie of the pie as
well so the the whole of season two is
about how he can
convince um the French connects to come
on his side so we can scrap off the
Italians but um The Twist of I didn't
even tell you what twist in season one
so one of the the main reasons why the
five families aren't like very cohesive
is because Vincent Gigante um DED
Stellar's old man not the black brother
there was a brother she was dating
before who is a son of one of the
fathers of the five families his name is
um swano Joe bonano so Jo banano son I
think his name is Steven they never
showed him but they just said he died
didn't know why didn't know how blah
blah he just said he died when he was
younger but the reason why he died was
because he was dating Stella he was 17
Stella was 13 apparently they banged oh
according to the show apparently they
banged obviously Gigante wasn't having
it he hired two black Brothers to dppy
him and then Vincent dppy the two black
Brothers but blamed the kill obviously
on the two black Brothers you see what
I'm saying facts so that's crazy yeah
yeah so uh Joe bonano always assumed
that it's just the black gu he that's
why he's hated just hates blacks just
hates blacks because of this situation
not knowing that it's his boy that hired
the blacks you see what I'm saying but
that's how bumpy gets into it because
Stella has had enough Stella found out
told bumpy and bumpy said yeah this is
how I'm going to run the streets I'm
going to cause confusion in the street
thees among the families cuz I'm telling
banana if you don't believe me ask his
daughter the daughter B came out of the
car and spill it all they're at
War oh they're at War ju these men are
at War that's season two that's season
two that's like half of season two so
obviously stell's had two boyfriends now
the first banana guy and the black bre
that died yeah so all of our manag just
get duppi by the dad by the dad yes so
now remember I said to you in season one
um Ernie tried to do a thing with Stella
but on a slide thing but Ernie actually
really likes her Al so he's actually
trying to P he's actually trying to PN
her but Stella obviously hates
gun but over a period of time they
realized one the similar people and two
the person okay I take it back Vincent
didn't actually dppy the black brother
he got someone else to D I'm when I say
the black bre I mean um Teddy musician
he got someone else to do it the same
way he got someone else to do banano son
okay okay okay okay but the brother he
got to do it was Vincent's best
friend do you see what I'm saying
Vincent's best friend is the one that
DED off the you okay but Ernie was meant
to dppy him off in the first place but
Ernie and um his name is Benny the
person that DED him Ernie and Benny are
obviously in the same crew with Vincent
so Ernie was trying to warn Stella like
yo like he's feeling her now I'm trying
to warn you and he was with Stella was
with the man with Teddy I'm trying to
warn you man listen I know you don't
like me but you man need to leave town
because Benny Benny's trying to do up a
thing like literally man was singing
came out the concert came out the show
with Stella handin hand Ernie came
through said yo you maned to leave Benny
Round the Corner Bang bang dropped him
why is he got to be walking around
holding hands with this girl he when I
say he doesn't care he just loves her he
loves they tried to go to the Teddy's
mom wants to smack him every time I bet
want saying this white girl is going to
get you killed every week week in week
out this white girl is going to get you
killed yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah fam
Benny just bang bang he DED him twice
and he's like
damn that was the end of season two
season uh no sorry that was the tail end
of like midseason 2 but it kept on going
in the sense of Ernie trying to regain
Stella's trust and like because Stella
was like I'm I'm done with this family
Charing this whole I'm killing Benny I
don't care what you say I'm a Gigante
deep down so I'll do what I want I'm
killing Benny man Benny's gant's best
friend they man have been about to
together it's like it's like one of them
trying to Dy me you see what I'm saying
yeah
yeah so she she she kind of like creates
a plan and blah blah blah it doesn't
really work at first but it gets to a
point where she sees him by himself she
has a gun she shoots him and duppies him
in the leg but coincidentally Ernie's in
the same space and Ernie is now confused
he points his gun to her like what have
you done do you know the position you're
putting me in Benny's like shoot her
shoot her shoot her he points the gun to
him pops him in his oh pops him in his
head this girl's got everyone Twisted
she's got everyone twisted and you know
the maddest thing gant's brother Dominic
FASA is a priest so he confesses
everything to his brother oh I've seen
him do that yeah yeah yeah and obviously
she confesses everything to the brother
so that's like the family priest and
it's it's it's just bunk he got all the
source on everyone all the source on
everyone and she said she said um she
said before before she kills um before
she kills Benny the reason why I'm doing
this or the reason why I'm telling you
this okay she long story short she told
him in the end she said the reason why
I'm telling you this is because I'm
tired of all these lies let's just be a
truthful family pick what do you want do
you want this Gang family or do you want
your family you have to pick you have to
pick bro and she oh yeah that that was
long but how the season ended was long
story short before Stella said to uh
Gigante saying listen I like Ernie we're
going to try and make this work blah
blah blah treat him like you would treat
any of my other boyfriends don't mess
this up prior to her she said that to
her dad she said that to her dad oh
Jesus this is post Benny Duppy but they
had kind of somewhat made up per se but
and little does she know that the dad
dupp is all the
boyfriends yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so
prior to that
conversation she obviously he was livid
about the Benny situation and obviously
found out that Ernie popped him in the
head oh God so he got one of his other
boys to take Ernie to some bank cuz
there was a riot in Harlem um so they
were focused on keeping like the
affluent areas safe but there was a bank
in like deep black Harem that was empty
so he's like let's Rob that to get some
people blah he said take Ernie with you
oh Jesus then obviously the conversation
with Stella happened and then gigant was
like oh my God what kind of world am I
in I've just tried to dppy him but now
you're telling me my daughter wants me
to save him blah blah blah he ran to the
bank say Ernie where are you Ernie where
are you he's like I'm here I'm here what
going on he's like oh where's thingy oh
he just said it Bang bang bro gone and
he obviously the next scene after that
was him talking to his daughter you know
I tried my best I didn't mean to do this
trying everything and he starts walking
off you realize he in handcuffs she sold
the whole family out oh she said enough
is enough enough is strike three strike
three boyfriend three strike three yeah
season 3 episode one he's not in the
episode he's in B bro oh he's in pen bro
Stella's yeah Stella is doing bits
now
continuing stell's we're in season three
now we're in season three now Vincent's
misses is Katherine uh her name is
Olympia in the show but that's not
Stella's Mom it's a stepmom so Olympia
found out obviously Olympia knows
everything now because Stella baited the
whole thing Olympia got one of the other
heads of the five families to find
someone to try and dppy Stella oh Christ
obviously though you put my man in pen
but that's the daughter of the boss bro
you see what I'm saying you see the
conflict brother it's crazy oh yeah I've
just realized she asked one of the heads
of the other five families to kill the
daughter of one of another heads of the
five families that's what I'm saying
that's a war what are you asking of me
every other episode These man talk about
war these man say it's going to be a war
it's going to be a war it's going to be
a war and it bro nine times at 10 it's a
war bro so now we're kicking off season
3 with a with a war we're kicking off
season 3 with a potential War because
obviously Stella didn't let happen
Stella was intuitive like she's a
Gigante in the end she's a Gigante in
the end she did what she had to do she
did what she had to do man that's the
that's the title of the whole thing
she's a Gigante in the end she's a
Gigante in the end my bro o okay yeah
bro season free started off with an
absolute Bang Yeah Yeah Yeah Yeah Yeah
it's a good show yeah sounds like a show
fam it's it's it's I can't wait for the
next episode long story short long story
short I can't wait for the next episode
so guys make sure you check out the new
season of Godfather Harlem streaming now
on lioncap plus Sensational yes okay
guys let's take a very quick break
because today we are brought to you by
manscaped manscaped have taken a step up
from
Bolen take a step from B to bring your
face the cleanest shaved is ever seen so
this season no need to toil in trouble
manscapes all new handyman is the best
way to get rid of that stubble rhymes on
rhymes on Rhymes how I'm going to say
bro the when I dropping bars today
featuring a compact design and nextg
skin safe technology the handyman was
designed to give you that smooth finish
without the mess of a traditional shave
get the sweetest treat this Halloween by
going to manscape.com and use this code
sng Z November gol for 20% off plus free
shipping let's get back to the juicy
juicy chip chat rsky trash news please
sir a priest broke his seal of
confession to put a cheating wife on
blast to her husband oh dear oh dear
indeed oh dear he broke some rules and
he's going to hell bro where's where's
the what's the word I'm looking for the
the the confidentiality the O the confid
yeah bro fam non-existent Prest lawyer
like you can't be spilling my stuff
check it a priest violated his
confession seal in order to inform the
husband about an Unfaithful wife the
woman was in a true dilemma and believed
that Reddit was the only place where she
could get help the cheating woman went
to the legal council subreddit to see if
she could file a lawsuit against her
priest she posted about cheating on her
husband while traveling for work in
2022 Mary didn't feel especially bad
about it at the time since she has her
husband since she and her husband were
on a Shaky Ground raw so you post about
it so she posted on Beyonce's internet
okay but then came to her senses and she
she immediately felt horrible about the
situation so she she decided to come
clean to the priest as part of her
Penance the priest told her she had to
tell her husband what had happened
naturally this is not a simple undertake
undertaking so she paused to consider
her options so instead of checking in
with the cheating wife the priest felt
that he needed to update and spoke with
her and her husband instead I can't even
remember wow she returned home one
evening to discover him violently
tossing her belongings out of their
bedroom she deduced what had happened my
whole world is exploding because I
thought confession was supposed to be
private she wrote does this priests have
any kind of liability or
responsibility bro that's a that's a
good dilemma I'm not going to lie um it
is an interesting dilemma interesting
interesting I feel like
like it's it's very interesting someone
comment a priest violating his code
never heard that one before
facts rowned for doing stuff this is the
least of
it but I feel like in that aspect you
don't necessarily anyway continue I
don't know man well he said he need he
only spoke to the husband because he
needed an update so it sounded like he
he
assumed that the husband knew whether he
whether or not he it sounded like I'm
just checking in because I need I want
an update about what's going on not like
it's your business for an update
definitely not your business but the way
it's premised here is that he wasn't
spilling her
confession it was a case of she'd
confessed he's saying if you want to be
forgiven by the Lord you best go tell
your husband he assumed she wanted her
to get forgiven by the Lord so um she PA
so instead of checking in with the
cheating wife the priest felt the need H
felt he needed an update and spoke with
her husband instead so it didn't sound
like you don't know this and she
confessed this to me but she's been
cheating on you it sounded like he said
so how do you feel after your wife told
you yeah but it's also like you're not a
therapist you shouldn't some people I
promise you some some people treat as
therapist I get that but I also feel
like I don't think well I have no idea
because I've never been to a priest in
this manner or whatever but I also feel
like a priest shouldn't be asking the
questions you should let whoever come
into the room confess and speak and then
listen and then like add tidbits as and
when add hell Maries add prayers do you
see what I'm saying a priest shouldn't
you I I as the husband shouldn't come
into a a church sit down and a priest
would tell me so what's the update on
you and you're cheating wife do you see
what I'm saying that's you I think I
don't know bro this is his flock I think
you'll be surprised because to the
priest it doesn't say here that he told
the husband in the confession box true
okay yeah that that makes it worse no no
cuz he could have just seen the husband
on Sunday yeah and gone over to him and
been like cuz the open plane like I
agree with what you were saying if it
was in the confession box that's that's
I'm if the husband went in the
confession box and was speaking speaking
speaking then he's like oh by the way
how did this go that's not how it's
supposed to go but if it's just his
flock people go to priests with issues
all the time and they want the priest
advice on this that and the other so
he's probably confident to be like
um you must be really hurting right now
how's how's every how how you coping
he's like what the [__] he's what the
[__] are you talking about like
obviously Sarah and and Donnie banging
guys on Reddit yeah facts bangning guys
talking about it on Reddit how you
feeling and I said what and he said what
facts I told her she's going to hell if
she doesn't tell me fact he's pulling
his oh she wants hell she wants hell say
less my bad my bad my bad yeah so I I'm
I'm I'm playing Devil's Africa obviously
but
um yeah if it's premised that way I can
see that he hasn't really broken any
Oaths um I guess in that in that
scenario yeah I agree but I definitely
assumed it was the way F said same yeah
cuz I'm I'm looking at the picture I'm
seeing how it is I'm just deep as it's
in a confession box this confession box
pick here is like just looking me yeah
like he's literally whispering to my man
right there like yo fam yo fam so what
going with your wife chea wife I'd make
a terrible P I'm telling everyone
everyone's business I'm there's not a
wife in there that can come and tell me
she's a cheat there's not a wife there's
not a wife in that flock that she can
tell me she's a cheat and I'm not going
to tell a man there's not there's not a
single one why you wouldn't have a
congregation anymore yeah I wouldn't you
wouldn't have anyone I CU I like sleep I
like peace bro I'm not I'm not finding
this stuff out plus first of all don't
cheat second of all don't tell me you
cheated posted it on Reddit and I'm the
criminal yeah facts told the Internet
it's free as far as I'm concern it's
free game fact if you're posting it
online it's free game facts um but yeah
it's a bit mad the but yeah at the same
time the confidence that she has to be
like I'm trying to Sue this priest does
someone help me no one should be helping
you do anything facts you posted on
redit for good sake yeah you don't get
to cheat on your husband post it on
Reddit and then when [__] comes to bite
you in the ass you be like [__] this
priest yeah
this is this is this is your cake this
is your cake bro eat it what what did
the um comment say there you go don't
cheat at
all oh here we go we you done the same
thing if it was the husband shut up man
she's more wor about how priest um her
priest thousand set of our own
fact oh that's a Twist of Rooney that's
a Twist of Rooney never been so close to
hitting the like Jesus that's fact can't
feel bad for a person that cheats but
the piece did break the p to break the V
both got wrong don't cheat only confess
to God not
humans what oh why don't they do that
when one of their homies touches
children children all right next next
yeah yeah next next next charge charge
charge it's a family show so I've got a
dilemma hit me bro so I found this one
well someone I didn't find it someone
sent it a few people sent this to me
from the old classic uh six brown chicks
page okay they get the juiciest they do
I'm not going like they need they
deserve their flowers cuz we've been
asking for dilemmas for years now and
we've had some juicy ones these man stay
consistent with their juice they do they
do always always it's wild so Props to
them yeah right this one all hit me I
left my wife of 23 years for a younger
woman who works at the car wash Jesus he
saw a fantasy and ran with it left my
wife for a 23 year-old woman um for no
no no sorry 23 years 23 years for a
younger woman for a younger woman who
works at the car wash Jesus I tell her
about life show her around
Etc I in brackets I spend a little money
on her not too much irrelevant
irrelevant irrelevant information I love
when people speckled dust of of Deceit
and just trying to distract me with
stuff get to the point bro I
not I noticed she had my number saved
under wisdom on her phone that shows age
difference already I'm unattracted
already under wisdom on her phone
flipping out I figured she called me
wisdom because I teach her so much about
life my 18-year-old daughter sent me a
tick Tok video of that my young
girlfriend made in the video she said
I'm so poor I'm [__] an old man who's
shaped like a wisdom
tooth
no what plot twist Fam I'm so poor I'm
[__] an old man who's shaped like a
wisdom tooth and he has the audacity to
be
cheap where and then him where do I go
from here confront her or just move on
I'm hurt and embarrassed advice there is
no advice wow tick tock not even a tweet
bro she didn't care Tik Tok care if you
saw it my daughter sent it to me it's
your fault why you leaving your wife of
23 years for a [__] car wash Lady
it's your fault it's your fault you get
you report you so myud she has nothing
to do but make Tik toks facts bro facts
bro you reap what you oh my days man's
asking for help bro advice I left my
wife and this new thing is is is
embarrassing me on Tik Tok she said I
look like a wisdom dude women are so
specific you know what wisdom Dude Looks
Like It's fat and it's got two little
legs that's crazy bro it's fat on top
and it's got two skinny little
legs and man said I'm saved as wisdom is
it because of I teach us so much about
life
Wow a it's cuz man fat on top yeah
that's a that's a spinner roony like you
said wow what do I do there's nothing
you can do my my good sir it's charged
the fact that your daughter had to send
that to you address your midlife Cris
and move on facts that's that that's
second that's such secondhand
embarrassment as the child I would never
want to see that I'm so poor I'm dating
an old man who's shaped like a wisdom
tooth and he's cheap too and he has the
audacity to be cheap the that the
audacity audacity to be cheap is
Relentless
bro me and my oh God if I find myself a
bachelor at 60 yeah and there's a young
thing that wants it and I'm gassed and I
find Tik toks of saying I'm dating a man
who's oh I can't even say it he's shaped
like a wizd my hand will shake and shake
and Shake crack the iPhone 16 I crack it
in my
hand my 18-year-old show me this she's
been seeing it facts bro I couldn't
click on the comments you can never yeah
you can never that's that moment I would
stare at myself in the mirror for hours
you would it's one of them ones where I
wouldn't discuss it with my daughter or
my child or whatever but I would also
know she's got the leverage for years to
come she gets what she wants she gets
what she wants now she gets what she
wants and I'm H in the gym fact cuz I've
embarrassed my surname bro she has to
move she has this story until the day
she dies wow when people ask about her
dad this is what will come to her mind
wow factual factual he left my mom after
23 years of marriage for a car wash
chick and he found I found out that she
was passing him on Tik Tok said he's
shaped like a wisdom
tooth I
would find a what's what's that thing
where you you like go away from your
parents what's it called like
emancipation I'd emancipate yeah I'd
have to emancipate if you're the
daughter I can't be tied with that yeah
yeah yeah you can't I can't be tied
can't you can't you can't you can't you
can't that's Bonkers bro it's the worst
that's it's the worst level of
embarrassment I've ever heard it's the
worst thing bro because I can forward
thinking I can see
the midlife crisis and I can see I
thought I was down and out and this
young thing wants me she wants me only
to be told on the internet that I'm a
[__]
joke and I've got the audacity to be
cheap that that last bar the audacity to
be cheap it's not my fault it's not my
choice bro you think old and rich just
yeah they Cay I'm just old yeah facts
I'm just old bro damn she wanted that
Silver Fox oh I'm so poor and she's
she's using
me as an example of how sad her life is
facts do you know how horrible that is
she's using me as an example to say look
how bad my life is look at what I'm
doing this is my man everyone feels
sorry for me he's shaped like a
tooth that's crazy
that's oh oh bro that's that's nuts that
is nuts yeah no no no what a good
dilemma what dilemma solved a juic it's
a juicy one right so we've got a thread
yep yep yep everyone's been sending
sending me this thread all week one
thing I'm going to
address one thing I'm going to address
before we do this thread is that this is
another South African thread
yeah yeah right so let's just clear the
air with you man this week you might
have been getting carried away
so last time we did a South African frad
me and had mentioned that half of the
thread was in English and half of it
wasn't right so we said that it was
gibberish now there's there's a mishap
here in intended use of the word
gibberish facts facts we use gibberish
for everything yeah if I hear someone
with a stri accent that's gibberish
that's just noise yeah if someone
speaking overly intellectually to me and
I can't understand it you're speaking
gibberish if I'm in France gibberish
Spain
gibberish when I saw that you man
thought that we were saying that your
mother tongue is gibberish fam this is
actually dread let me actually do this
because I was alone in my bed and I had
to I'm not going to lie to you man I was
so confused I had to Google what
gibberish actually meant family someone
on Twitter um reposted the video and
then someone quote tweeted that and
saying I can't believe they spoke they
called it gibberish blah blah blah and
put the definition under I had to Google
what the definition of gibberish man cuz
I thought there's no way a nation is
this angry a nation there's no way an
entire nation is this angry about saying
gibberish I call everything gibberish
and no one said anything what does it
mean what cuz I gibberish just means I
don't understand Mumble yeah gibberish
just means I don't understand you bro so
when when I read it I was
like bro whenever jish yeah noun
unintelligible oh God meaningless oh God
bro nonsense oh God when I was like raw
okay myad ra ra ra apologies yeah you're
strong you're strong you're strong myad
myad myad if you man thought
that that we were saying that your
language is meaningless and
unintelligent and unintelligible come on
bro we're sorry obviously we did not
we're not saying that jez [__] hell
bro when I read that I was like ra so
one all seriousness guys if you
genuinely thought that's what we meant
and that's how you took it our sincerest
apologies we would never ever ever say
that your mother tongue is
unintelligible or meaningless facts we
the way we use the word it just means I
don't understand that's literally it so
again apologies we love you South Africa
oh another thing I need to hold my hands
up on I said that man was SP swah I'm
not going to lie that's Kenyan I'm sure
is it Kenyan it's B East African Google
that too you man have put me on game
this week because that's just what I
thought yeah yeah yeah yeah when you
said it I wasn't sure but I also didn't
have the balls to correct I was do you
know what I mean one of them on it was
one of them ones where it one of them
ones where like I was also saying it to
say it I wasn't actually I like yeah I
didn't know where I didn't know who
saidali Swahili I just said it again
didn't mean to be offensive I just said
it so then I had to Google what language
they speak in South Africa first of all
it's like 26 oh yeah there's lot few
yeah yeah I was like damn bro so again
if you were offended by that sorry I'm
sure when is like ca or something like
that yeah like xh or something yeah yeah
be but anyway guys let's have us clean
slate yeah we love you you love love we
didn't mean it please don't be vexed but
yeah you man have juicy juicy threads as
well so let's not burn Bridges let's not
stop Burning Bridges cuz you guys
provide the content we just spread the
word yeah but anyway starts off the
title of the thread is that phase where
you slowly start hating your girlfriend
is crazy this might be one of the
funniest threads is one of the funniest
St I've ever seen in my entire life bro
I was in The Barbers screenshotting once
to say for the show like holding my
breath I was in the chair holding my
breath didn't [__]
my it's hilarious yeah bro it's fact
right you can kick us off and then we're
just going to run it all right you'll be
wondering why your day is going so well
her battery died
bro oh my
God you you this is nuts you'll be
having a bad day and when she hugs you
it becomes even worse that's nuts bro oh
my God then someone commented under that
her hug feels like you're getting
mugged yo oh
oh man said I remember this one time on
a weekend she said she was coming yo I
[Laughter]
cried bro Donny said pretending to be
asleep and murmuring her girl best
friend's name in a sexy way so that she
gets a reason to leave Oh my days bro
that's Insanity that is insanity cuz
you're risking a broken nose you're
risking a broken a lot of things that's
Insanity facts
when she says talk to me and you know
she's not worth the effort so you just
tell her it's
fine that's tough she's not worth the
effort talk to me you know bro when her
kisses start to feel like being licked
by a dog wow
bro nah this one um it's a it's a
comment and then it's a screenshot of a
text message
it says when you know deep down this
isn't a typo and in the text says I wish
you were her yeah oh com here here
yeah bro slight pausing this the reason
this is so funny is because all brers
know this feeling oh yeah facts it's not
always with a girlfriend it could just
be with a Ting Ting yes yes yes and this
ties into that PNC mentality as well yes
yes and you're just like don't touch me
me don't speak to me done with you bro
when you wake up and see that good
morning handsome and you're just like
[__] off facts Bro [__] off what is this
don't I'm not handsome to you Fu I'm not
your handsome I'm not your man yeah yeah
yeah your Butters bro stop have I been
banging you for 3 months yes am I over
it
yes bro
oh god um when you're wondering why
you're having such a peaceful day and it
turns out she was giving you the silent
Dre that's oh brutal when you keep
messing up a purpose so that she gives
you a reason to break up and she keeps
forgiving you damn Jaren fam this one
when you receive her text and it's like
a debit
order fam a text from your go is like
someone asking you for money oh my days
ah you'll be ghosting her and she will
still be texting you like I just want to
make sure you're okay you can talk to
me I'd want to throw my phone bro this
one was the craziest
one when you have to spit on her back to
pretend that you came because she
doesn't turn you on
anymore that's that's uncalled for
that's that's actually Beyond out of
order yeah that's uncalled for that's
too far that one had replies I can
imagine that one had replies imagine
this one you start asking yourself
things like does she have to chew when
she eats yeah bro the
infuriation
wow oh when you open a text thinking
it's from the woman you actually want
but it's from her
oh Savage when she holds your hand in
public and you feel like cutting it
off oh my God that made snore oh my god
wow oh my god when she says I'll call
you when I get home then you switch off
your phone and remove the
battery they're removing the batter's
BRAC he doesn't want to
with anyone there's no chance you're
getting through to me remove the battery
czy oh right um when you walk past a
group of with her on purpose and no one
tries to take her off your
hands oh that's a Next Level when you
when you no longer have an ego about her
that's another level fam this
one this one might be the same as yours
when when the problem asks you what the
problem
is this one when her smile takes away
yours
no
no can't breathe oh
God
oh God the funest when you decide to
unlock your phone so she could check any
time oh my
God sometimes having a girlfriend is
like having an OP you're forced to see
oh my God Jesus I think I'm done same
bro I think I'm done bro wow wow thre
what a thread man wow what a thread woo
what a day right we're going to leave
the episode there for you guys thank you
very much facts again sa we love you
we're sorry we do love you with all our
hearts with all our hearts bro that was
a tough
week some guy
said man some guy commented on one of
our videos these man think my tongue is
gibberish yeah would take this and he
start sing bars I had to translate all
of them basically suck your mom iwear I
said raw suck your mom Jesus it was nuts
Oh my days anyway guys thank you for
today facts it's been good always love
love love gang gang gang
[Music]
bless